ahora vamos a ver la región química de
reacciones de dos así es que tenemos por
aquí la reacción lo primero que vamos a
hacer es pasar por el mecanismo dibujar
nuestros productos y a partir de ellos
vamos a pensar acerca de la región
selectividad de esta reacción aquí a la
izquierda tenemos nuestro alumno de
alquilo y aquí está nuestra base fuerte
óxido de sodio el sodio tiene una carga
positiva y el año net óxido una negativa
como tenemos aquí una base fuerte
sabemos que este es un mecanismo de
reacción de 2 en nuestro sustrato este
carbono que está directamente enlazado
con el halógeno es el carbono alfa y
todos los carbonos directamente
enlazados con el carbono alfa son los
carbonos beta por lo que a éste le voy a
llamar beta 1 este va a ser vetados y
este beta 3 así es que el stoke sido de
sodio es una base muy fuerte y se va a
llevar
de alguno de estos tres carbonos beta
empecemos con beta 1 aunque ahí tenemos
por aquí el mismo alero de alquilo este
de acá es beta 1 vamos a dibujar uno de
sus protones el angelet óxido es una
base muy fuerte y la vamos a dibujar por
acá tiene una carga formal negativa y
tres pares libres de electrones y el
anio net óxido va a llegar y se va a
llevar a este protón y entonces los
electrones de este enlace se van a pasar
para acá para formar un doble enlace y
exactamente al mismo tiempo los
electrones de este enlace se quedan con
el bromo que se desenlaza de la molécula
y el producto nos queda así los
electrones de este enlace se movieron
para acá y ahora están formando este
doble enlace ok para obtener este
producto tomamos un protón del carbono
beta 1 pero obtendríamos exactamente el
mismo producto si tomáramos un protón
del carbono beta 2 lo que sí nos daría
un producto
y si tomamos un protón del carbono beta
3 así es que por acá
este es el carbono beta 3 y vamos a
dibujar uno de sus protones tenemos por
acá el año net óxido con sus pares de
electrones libres y su carga formal
negativa y entonces el año net óxido
llega y se lleva este protón estos
electrones se pasan para acá para formar
un doble enlace y los electrones que
están uniendo al bromuro con la molécula
se van con el bromuro que es nuestro
grupo saliente y nos queda este al que
no los electrones de este enlace se
movieron para acá y ahora están formando
este doble enlace y listo
estos son los dos productos de esta
reacción ahora resulta que el al que no
de la derecha este por acá es el
producto mayoritario siempre obtenemos
una mayor cantidad de este al que no y
el al que no de la izquierda es el
producto minoritario porque siempre que
realizamos esta reacción obtenemos una
menor cantidad de éste al que no y aquí
ya estamos hablando de región química
por lo menos estamos hablando de en qué
parte de la molécula se está formando el
doble enlace por lo tanto se dice que
esta reacción es región selectiva porque
favorece la producción de alguno de sus
isómeros y por supuesto ahora vamos a
hablar acerca de por qué sucede bueno
pues el producto mayoritario es un al
que no más estable porque está más
sustituido si nos fijamos en los
carbonos del enlace doble podemos ver
fácilmente que aquí tenemos 1 2
tres grupos al kilos por lo que este es
un al que no tres sustituido mientras
que el al que no de la izquierda el
producto minoritario aquí tenemos los
carbonos del doble enlace y tiene
únicamente dos grupos al kilos es un al
que no de sustituido y sabemos por lo
que hemos visto acerca de la estabilidad
de los al que nos que entre más
sustituidos sea un al que no más
estables y al más sustituido de todos le
llamamos el producto de záitsev porque
es el producto mayoritario es el al que
no más estable ahora esta es una parte
muy interesante porque en esta reacción
con esta base fuerte stock sido de sodio
tenemos una reacción región selectiva
pero si cambiamos la base obtenemos
otros resultados ok si tenemos esta
reacción con esta base fuerte & óxido de
sodio lo que tenemos es una reacción
región selectiva pero las cosas se ponen
interesantes
cuando cambiamos la base vamos a volver
a hacer esta reacción pero ahora
cambiando la base ahora tenemos terc
butilo de potasio por acá tenemos una
carga positiva en el potasio y una
negativa en el oxígeno por supuesto
tenemos el mismo sustrato el mismo al
duro de alquilo y vamos a tener los
mismos productos pero en esta reacción
la base está impedida estéticamente ok
el ttr butilo de potasio está
estéticamente impedido así es que por
acá cuando dibujamos las bases de la
reacción anterior aquí tenemos los
stocks y dos ahora queremos dibujar por
acá unter woodstock sido así es que le
agregamos lo que le falta también lo
agregamos por acá y la reacción sucede
de la misma forma el ter wood óxido
llega y se lleva a un protón ya sea del
carbono beta 1 o del carbono beta 2 y
nos queda este al que no como producto
que es un al que no es sustituido
por acá si la unión de óxido llega y se
lleva a un protón del carbono beta 3 se
forma este otro al que no trees
sustituido pero la diferencia es que
esta vez en esta reacción con esta base
el producto mayoritario es el al que no
es sustituido en esta reacción
producimos una mayor cantidad de al que
nos dé sustituidos y el producto
minoritario es el tri sustituido
producimos una menor cantidad de al que
nos 3 sustituidos y podemos explicar que
suceda esto porque el test butóxido de
potasio es una molécula impedida
estéticamente y eso significa que esta
molécula es muy estorbosa y entonces es
más fácil que se lleve protones que
están más al alcance por ejemplo estos
protones de los carbonos beta 1 y beta 2
es bastante fácil que la base llegue a
estar cerca de ellos pero por acá el
impedimento estético de
esta molécula junto con el impedimento
estético de este alumno de alquilo hacen
que sea más difícil que la base se lleve
a algunos de estos protones y por eso es
que él al que no trim sustituido resulta
ser el producto minoritario si estamos
utilizando una base que esté
estéticamente impedida como sucede con
el textil o de potasio y es por esto que
en esta reacción el producto mayoritario
sea el menos sustituido ya estos
productos le llamamos productos de
hoffman y es el producto mayoritario
cuando usamos una base estéticamente
impedida así es que debemos de fijarnos
muy bien en cuál es la base que se está
utilizando cuando tenemos una reacción
de eliminación y 2 si la base es una
base fuerte no impedida estéticamente
entonces el producto mayoritario va a
ser el al que no más sustituido el
producto de state set
por otro lado si usamos una base fuerte
que si es estéticamente impedida como el
ter butilo de potasio entonces el
producto de hoffman es el mayoritario el
producto menos sustituido